labour is against independence in
scotland but this does
seem to be yet another election all
about independence
doesn't scotland need greater powers in
order to fight its way
out of of covert and and manage its
recovery
i think there's certainly more need for
more devolution and i think people in
liverpool birmingham manchester cardiff
feel that just like they do in glasgow
where i'm sitting in other parts of
scotland so we can have a recovery that
works for everyone
but just on the first point jane it's
politicians that want to talk about
independence in this election
campaign it's the conservatives and the
snp who want to make this election
campaign
about which side you were on in a
referendum in 2014
but in actual fact covenant choose
between yes no leave and remain
the aftermath is not going to choose
between yes no leaving remain
this is a pandemic election not a normal
election and i think too many of the
other political parties and other
politicians
forget that 10 000 of our fellow
citizens have lost their lives
and what this election must be about and
that's what i'm focusing on what the
labour party is focusing on
and what the next parliament has to be
about is that national recovery so we
can come through
this most difficult year that has been
for all of us in our lifetime
and actually build a stronger and fairer
nation and that's the case we'll be
making
in the last 11 days of this campaign and
you maybe need to be speaking to some of
you for your labor candidates because
i've got a list here of ones that
that have got quotes on independence and
the problem seems to be
that that the line coming from the
labour party is slightly confused and
woolly
uh dundee city west candidate mercedes
villalba in favor of another another
referendum now this is from just january
if we're not truly content with the
status quo hadn't we better call for a
referendum to put our alternative to the
people
dundee east candidate own right again
this january
i wouldn't go as far as being
pro-independence and supporting yes
being a requirement but definitely being
favor
of a second indie ref would help bring
back voters to the party
uh lothian's candidate nick ward again
in january
this year um i do not think that
acknowledging the right to
self-determination and accepting that if
a majority empowerment wants a second
referendum is a silly position so
there are a lot of people who will say
that the labor party doesn't have a
consistent
you know policy on this no it does jen
because what people are talking about
there is
of course scotland has a right to choose
his own future but what we are all
united on in this election campaign our
manifesto makes it clear
is that we do not support independence
we don't support a referendum we believe
the next parliament should be focused
entirely
on delivering a national recovery and
pulling our country back together
not going back to those old arguments
not going back to the old divisions
and that is a case that only labor is
making in a serious way in this election
campaign and all our candidates
are unified on that but you might not
support independence but it does seem
that quite a lot of your candidates
support a referendum what are you not
worried that the very pro unionist
labour party party voters are going to
vote conservative this time around
no no i told the challenge you have the
clear fault line in our election
and the clear fault line in scottish
politics is that we have 14 years of an
snp government
seven years of nicholas sturgeon and
first minister and in that time there
have been catastrophic failures of
government
and whenever there is a failure the snp
either says
we would it wouldn't have happened if we
had independence or worse still what
they say is
it might have been bad but look at that
mob over there at least we're not as bad
as them
pointing at the tories frankly scotland
deserves better than that and uk
deserves better than that and that's why
this election campaign
has got to be about the next five years
and how we make
what has been a really really difficult
year how we come through and make a
fairer and stronger country
not going back to those arguments and
and that's been the central part of my
leadership for eight weeks
in this job it's a central part of my
leadership for the last two weeks as we
lead up to that election
and i give the cast and guarantee to
every single person watching this
program
what i'm putting forward is not a case
for half of the country that agree with
me on the constitution
i'm making a case for all of scotland
because i want
to come through this most difficult of
yours and have a recovery that works for
everyone
no matter what the traditional position
on the subject of recovery you have a
national recovery plan
offers various things promises various
things including 60 000 jobs for
recovery
um lot of bold promises but questions
about how you would fund it the ifs has
had a look at your figures and said
you'd have to substantially increase
scottish taxes and would need to double
the unallocated funding available to the
scottish government this year
to meet these manifesto promises are you
not writing checks that you're not in
cash well we dispute that because there
isn't there is an overlap in terms of
some of the spending commitments we have
made
so some of the spending commitments we
have made we've allocated the full
budget
but there are overlap in terms of
smaller amounts of budget that the smp
have allocated but we want to go further
than them
in terms of some projects i'll give you
one practical example of that and
we believe that there's going to be a
jobs crisis coming through this pandemic
and i don't want us to wait till after
the lockdown ends or after the virus
finally disappears for us to start
investing in that new jobs for the
future
so we have published the most ambitious
and largest job creation scheme
in the history of the scottish
parliament not 60 000 jobs
170 000 new jobs and i'm not shy about
the price tag it'll cost 1.2
billion but we have billions of pounds
of unallocated
recurring and non-recurring spend
available to us in the scottish budget
what are we waiting for we need to be
using that right now
to plan for the recovery start the
recovery right now so we do not have a
lost generation coming through this
pandemic
do you accept though that it will lead
to tax rises in scotland you said during
the the
labor leadership campaign in scotland
that you'd bring forward more radical
tax policies than jeremy corbyn so who
in scotland is going to be paying more
tax under you
well we'll be clear i i support a more
progressive tax system but i believe we
can use the billions of pounds that are
unallocated
alongside that i want to create a new
tax in scotland that targets those big
online giants like amazon who have done
such
a phenomenal success through these most
difficult times in terms of their
profits
let's tax companies like amazon
appropriately let's use that money to
invest in the high street to invest in
jobs so we can what about individual
taxpayers though
and then we have made a commitment that
we will not look to increase personal
taxation over the course of the
parliament
but if in the later part of the
parliament if we do have a deficit that
we need to meet with tax rises
we would only consider a tax rise in the
first instance of those earning over 150
000 pounds a year
and then those earning over a hundred
thousand pounds a year but our
presumption is against
personal income taxes so you're
confident that you can raise this 1.2
billion just for big business
the 1.2 billion i think we have already
have the 1.2 billion is already
available to us in terms of our first
year of spend
it's for the longer term as we go into
year three four and five of the
parliament
that i think we can have a substantial
budget but if we have a gap in our
budget
only in that moment we look at personal
income tax rises for those at the very
very
top do you think you're tough enough to
take on nicola sturgeon
um a lot of people think that she's had
a very good
covert outbreak and has done herself a
lot of favors
if it comes down to it can you take her
on absolutely absolutely can take her on
and i'm standing directly in her own
constituency
as a demonstration of that but look i i
don't want to take her on the way that
previous politicians want to take people
on which is
shouting at them getting angry at them i
think our politics deserves better than
that
i'm going to do it with honesty i'm
going to do with humility
i'm going to do with empathy i'm going
to do it with unity and i want to spread
hope across the country
because that's the way we get the labour
party back on track but more importantly
that's the way we rebuild the country we
all love would you be interested in
forming another coalition with the lib
dems
no coalitions with anybody but i'm happy
to work with any individual political
party or any individual on
one-off issues so for example i've
worked with every single political party
in the parliament
around tackling prejudice and hate in
all its forms my party worked with the
snp around the period products bill
and the protection of retail workers
bill i've worked with the liberal
democrats to get a public inquiry into
mental health services and more funding
for mental health services
i've worked with the greens around
reversing the sqa exams fiscal from last
year so
individual issues i'm happy to work with
anyone because if we can't come together
at a time of national crisis
when can we come together so that's the
challenge i lay down to every other
political party
is forget the divisions of the past
forget the old arguments
recognize that this is a pandemic
election where 10 000 of our fellow
citizens have lost their lives
and let our politics rise to the
occasion let's give scotland the
government
and the opposition it deserves and let's
give it the parliament it deserves so we
can make the best
it was being a really really difficult
situation